the year was 21 22 humanity had recently
begun his first real phase of mass-scale
Bionic body augmentations for the first
time it was now normal for people to
swap out body parts with more robust
technologically integrated prosthetics
for non-medical purposes a man named
Jack aged 29
had held off on all body modifications
for as long as he could and was of the
small remaining percentage of entirely
organic adult human bodies Jack worked
one of the few still existing physical
labor based jobs assisting in the
construction of keep and use of robotic
machinery used to load and unload cargo
shipping containers onto commercial
ships that self navigated themselves to
and from delivery ports while being one
of the few remaining workers with
biological arms and legs
Jack had inevitably fallen behind the
increasingly high standards of the job
naturally his biological arms and legs
grew tired and could exert only about
one fifteenth the force of the vast
majority of his co-workers who had opted
for the company funded cyber build brand
mechanical prosthetic arms and legs in
order to stay afloat in the competitive
automated job market on June 3rd 21:24
Jack finally opted into giving up his
biological arms and legs for Bionic
replacements these Bionic prosthetics
operated by implanting various
electrodes in areas of the brain that
control movement and process touch
sensation the electrodes were then
activated and engaged by the user's
brain neurons as the user thought about
and sensed movement directing nerve
signals back through the electrodes and
into the bionic limbs moving them
essentially just like biological arms
and legs following the procedure at the
Bionic surgery facility Jack filled out
all the necessary forms with his new
hands it was a bit tricky but not too
bad he found at the bottom of the form
he signed his name on the signature line
Jack Otis several years went by it took
Jack a little time to fully adapt and
get used to the idea of his new arms and
legs but fairly quickly he came to
barely even notice them initially he
didn't recognize them when he looked
down but since he never really
considered his arms and legs to be a
crucial part of his sense of identity
was relatively easy to eventually just
assimilate them as a part of him however
simultaneous to Jack getting fully
accustomed to the new appendages with
technology and medical advancements
seeming to only continue to multiply
much of the rest of humanity had begun
taking on other newly developed more
extreme Bionic augmentations in order to
keep up with the increasingly
competitive automated job market as well
as the heightening standards of living
over the span of about 15 years by age
45 Jack had exchanged out his rib cage
spine eyes ears teeth heart several
other organs and eventually his skull
and neck the augmented replacements
provided technological integrations that
synchronized with external devices while
also improving bodily strength
functionality and longevity these
modifications were also intended to aid
in slowing down the aging process and
extending the universal average lifespan
which with many of these initial Bionic
replacements was predicted to easily
extend in in past two or three hundred
years at least at this point
Jack was essentially a human brain in a
vat atop an almost entirely different
mechanical body the riskiest procedure
which also happened to be the last one
Jack underwent was the skull replacement
that changed out his normal skull for a
bionic Lee integrated metal one
requiring his brain to be removed and
then placed back into the new head neck
and spinal configuration exteriorly the
skull looked like a completely normal
human head with otherwise
natural-looking skin and facial features
making the aesthetic transition fairly
benign however each person who underwent
the procedure was given the choice to
change how their face looked -
essentially anything they'd like which
Jack opted in for never having really
liked his face all that much he decided
on a new one that looked completely
different prior to and following the
procedure along with all the earlier
procedures Jack filled out and agreed to
a variety of lengthy waiver and
clearance forms signing his name on each
jack outis within only a year of each
procedure sometimes just a few months
jack mostly became used to his new
augmented body parts the face was of
course the hardest and longest one to
adapt to
but eventually within the year or so he
started to recognize himself in it just
the same as his old one
his face was never really him anyway
Jack felt it was merely just the cover
in front of him and any arrangement or
form of it could be him just as easily
at least once he got used to it
ultimately he lived contently with his
new bionic body feeling like no more
than just a physically improved version
of his original self several more years
would go by by this point as a result of
increasing artificial intelligent
development Jack had been automated out
of his original job field and the global
socio-economic system had shifted away
from nearly all physical based jobs
consequently after a harsh transition
period new industries markets and jobs
started to take form across the internet
landscape especially related to things
like VR AR art communication
experiencial services software and so on
Jack eventually landed a job as a set
designer and coder for virtual reality
entertainment performances as a result
of this shift the long-anticipated
mass-market consumer application of
implantable brain machine interfaces was
approved during this time in the year
21:46 the company Nurit I led the charge
beginning their first consumer market
rollout with their model bi brain
machine interface like all brain machine
interfaces it works by implanting tiny
chips into the Bionic or organic skull
of the user tiny wires would then be
connected from these chips and spread
out into various essential parts of the
brain the wires could then receive and
send messages from and through the users
neurons as a result the user could
connect their brain to the cloud and via
brainwaves alone operate devices and
Bionic technologies communicate
non-verbally with others online as well
as share and access public information
essentially merging thought with
Internet and wearable technology one of
the most notable features of the
interface was that it allowed users to
select and deselect technical skills and
aptitudes that could be downloaded
directly into the brain as if they had
been learned or forgotten over a
lifetime in just a matter of seconds
by activating patterns and sequences of
nerve impulses the technology rendered
specific body movements and mental
abilities that carried out various
skills like all prior augmentations the
brain machine interface was fully
optional every step of the way
including this one one was faced with
the choice to either augment or not
however inevitably most if not all
conceded eventually due to the apparent
will to life that technology possessed
and carried out through human
socialization for many years
recreational brain machine interfaces
confronted especially high resistance by
groups that were against the general
consumer adoption of the technology for
many prior decades the technology had
been exclusively approved and used for
medical purposes only
strictly assisting with neurological
disorders and body paralysis
now however because of the need for
enhanced mental capacities and digital
integrations the technology was approved
and set to be used more or less to
modify otherwise quote-unquote healthy
human brains Jack was one of the many
who initially opposed it it was one
thing to relinquish parts or even the
full body but to go into the more
abstract parts of the brain was
something else entirely
Jack and others like him thought however
just like all the prior augmentations
the technology exponentially creeped
itself into the norm as more and more
individuals adopted it creating a
greater sense of ostracization and
exclusion towards those who did not like
most things like it it reached its
inevitable tipping point and went from
abnormal to have one too abnormal to not
eventually Jack underwent the simple and
essentially painless procedure and awoke
into a new technologically integrated
brain after going through a brief moment
of recovery he turned on the interface
viewing it through his bionic Lea
augmented eyes he mentally filled in his
name on the startup screen Jack outis it
was weird at first but mentally deciding
to write versus mentally deciding to
write and then watching your arm do it
were fundamentally no different Jack
found and he took to it almost right
away as time would pass and Jack became
more and more used to his newly modified
brain he downloaded and relinquished
certain skills and aptitudes and so on
after a certain point to Jack's relief
it became clear that fundamentally there
wasn't anything really changing about
him at least no more or less than just
learning new skills throughout Jack's
biological life he had learned and
forgotten many skills ideas capacities
and so on but still always felt like the
same person and here too despite the
extreme rate the same phenomenon seemed
to occur he realized he was never as
technical skills or abilities but rather
the person experiencing them as the
modern world move further into the
digital mental realm new brain machine
interface companies and models came out
aggressively competing with each other
corporations started to more commonly
generate and push software updates to
consumers as an effort to keep their
models at the forefront some of the
software updates were relatively benign
and were no more than bug fixes or
additional skill set options or better
integrations with Bionic prosthetics
however some software updates began to
go further dipping into desires
interests habits and the like users who
moved forward with these updates could
do things like increase or decrease
tendencies towards certain states remove
undesirable desires and download or
delete interests naturally these
software updates were again met with
reluctancy by many Jack along with
plenty of others like him avoided any
updates that altered more than just the
existing functionality for as long as
they could Jack felt strongly that the
alterations of tendencies or desires or
interests would change his entire sense
of self-identity and render him
unfamiliar to himself however as time
passed in the same pattern of history
unfolded Jack along with the majority of
others like him eventually opted in and
downloaded some of these software
updates in the year 2153 Jack downloaded
his first major software update known as
version crime an update that allowed
users to control and self-regulate
personal desires habits and interests
upon the download as usual Jack had to
read the Terms of Service and digitally
sign his name where asked on which he
signed Jack out
following the software update through
essentially no more than a push of a
button Jack could and did download and
delete desires interests and daily
routines often relinquishing old ones to
make room for the new across Jack's
entire lifetime prior to the neuro Tiber
an interface he experienced many
different interests desires habits and
life routines and never felt like a
different person
even if one desire or interest led to
another the transitional period of time
between them always kept him feeling
like him although more extreme the
software update seemed to feel no
different since Jack was still always
the one choosing to download or delete
these features of himself it all still
felt like it was based off of his
foundational desire for certain desires
interests and routines strung along a
consistent non broken line of
self-identity and so even though Jack
had a nearly completely different body
new set of technical skills new desires
and interests and new daily life at this
point in his mind he still felt like
Jack in the Year 21:57 Jack downloaded
software update versions senior a brand
new revolutionary update that allowed
users to have memories added or removed
from the memory storage part of their
mind initially this was intended to be
used towards removing past memories of
trauma but it eventually evolved into
more general memory removal as well as
positive memory implantation users could
now plant false memories inside their
long-term memory bank altering how they
remembered the quality of their life
jack slowly but surely participated in
this to leading traumatic memories about
his former biological childhood self as
well as implanting nice memories
throughout his teens and 20s to
counterbalance the period of prolonged
depression he actually lived through
these alterations were integrated subtly
into the mind over time so that it felt
like the original memories simply faded
away and the new ones weren't even new
almost like how the biological mind
might block out or repaint bad memories
through oppression or nostalgia at this
point Jack forgot altered and had false
memories different interests desires
skills opinions and routines in an
almost completely different body
and yet even across all of this he
continued to feel like Jack it was as if
as long as he still had a continuous
memory of himself he sustained a
continuous tracking of himself and thus
a consistent sense of self-identity
regardless of any change or accurate
awareness of that change he recognized
that he was not the same person in any
way and perhaps couldn't even know what
that same person really was anymore but
yet somewhere in him something still
felt like him as part of the continual
development and improvement of the
technology Jack filled out optional
questionnaires about every month or so
at the top of each questionnaire form it
asked please confirm your identity who
are you
[Music]
you